so the first topic that I want to
discuss in this course is extrema graph
theory and in particular there's a whole
class of problems which have to do with
what happens if you forbid specific sub
graph and ask you what's the maximum
number of edges that can appear in your
graph in particular and this is the
question that we saw at the end of last
lecture which tells theorem essentially
asks if you know that your graph has no
triangles what's the maximum number of
edges it can have i ment else theorem
tells us that the extreme example is
when your graph consists of putting half
the vertices on one side half the
vertices on the other side and putting
in all the edges between so this is a
complete bipartite graph for these
partitions we denote complete bipartite
graphs like that and mentos theorem
tells us that this graph among triangle
free graphs has the most number of edges
triangle free
and vertices Haas at most so the number
of edges there is N squared divided by
four round down that many edges and from
this example this bound is tight so when
helstem gives us a completely
satisfactory answer to the question of
what's the maximum number of edges in a
graph without triangles and I want to
begin by showing you a few different
proofs of mental serum with illustrating
some different techniques in graph
theory
so we'll see quite a few proofs in
today's lecture the first one begins
well here's the setup I have G and
vertex graph and let me denote the
vertices and edges of G by if I have an
edge in G between vertices x and y then
note that they cannot have any common
neighbors because I would see a triangle
so what can we say about the degrees of
the two endpoints of this edge they
cannot add up to they cannot add up to
more than n so in particular exactly the
degrees of these two endpoints is at
most n whenever XY edge
well okay so now let me consider the
quantity which is the sum of the squared
degrees on one hand I claim that this
sum is equal to this quantity here where
I sum over all edges and the reason is
we'll look at the sum suppose imagine
writing out all the summons how many
times does each DX come up each DX
appears one for each edge accessing so
appears exactly the x times but we saw
from up here that each summon is at most
n so this sum here is that most a men on
the other hand let's consider the
quantity which is just the sum of the
degrees and you know sometimes known as
the handshaking lemma that the sums of
degrees is just twice the number of
edges each edge is considered twice in
this sum well now we apply the Cauchy
Schwarz inequality which as you'll see
many times in this course although you
might think of it as a fairly simple
inequality it's extremely powerful and
it will come up pretty much throughout
this course by the Cauchy Schwarz
inequality you compare these two
quantities I find that we have
this inequality over here relating the
sums of the degrees and square of the
sum of the degrees but we saw on one
hand the left hand side is for M Squared
and we also saw the right hand side is
that most M N squared putting them
together we see that M is that most N
squared over four and of course because
it's an integer it's at most the floor
of this number and that's a proof of
mental stare what can you tell me about
the Equality case in this proof I'll let
you think about that but let me show you
some other proofs in other words are
there graphs with the same number of
edges as the graph shown up there that
is also triangle frequent it's not a
unique example okay so let me show you a
different proof of Mancow still in this
proof so we begin with a step that seems
a little tricky let's let a be a subset
of vertices such that a is a largest
gee remember independent set is subset
of vertices with no edges inside you may
have many independent sets all having
the same maximum size take one of them
why should you do this step sometimes
magic happens
let's consider some vertex there's some
vertex let's say X and look at it
neighborhood the neighborhood must be an
independent set otherwise I get a
triangle and as a result the degree of
every vertex is at most the size of the
largest so now let the complement so I
have a every Edge has to intersect P the
edge cannot be entirely containing a
because a has no edges so the number of
edges of G is at most I count over
vertices in B the degree may be an over
count so the edges containing B I count
twice but that's okay so this is an
upper bound on a number of edges but I
also know that every vertex in the graph
has degree at most the size of a so
each someone is at most the size of a
and I have the terms now by the a MGM
inequality and the sizes of a and B add
up to the entire vertex set and squared
over 4 so that gives you another proof
of men house theorem what does this
proof tell us about the Equality case
you know something I always want you to
keep in mind when we do proofs is
especially if we have a type example
like that and later on and the course
will almost never have good examples
like that
so this is still early on in the course
we're still very clean examples is to
keep the extremal example in mind and
every step in your proof it should be
tight for that example otherwise
something went wrong with your proof
let's think about the inequalities and
equality we must have that so looking at
this inequality so there are no edges in
B we also have that by data every vertex
in B is complete 2a
and finally a and B should have the same
size so it is exactly the configuration
shown up there now when n is odd we're
rounding down by one so you can lose a
little bit and then you can check that
actually what we described up there is
also the unique example okay so so that
graphic complete bipartite graph with
two equal parts is the unique maximal
example number of edges in a triangle
free graph okay great so once we know
what the answer is for triangle free of
course we should ask further questions
instead of forbidding a triangle what if
we forbid other graphs so and what are
some natural next steps to take instead
of triangles we can ask what about if we
prepared a K for a clique of four
vertices or in general what if we forbid
a click on the fixed number of vertices
so what is the maximum edges there's a
good reason why index an R plus one so
for example if we're interested in K for
free so what might be a good candidate
for a graph with lots of edges that has
no K for certainly that example we saw
it does does not have K force because it
doesn't have any triangles or we can do
even better instead of taking two parts
you can take more parts for K for if I
take three parts each one n over three
number of vertices of course if and it's
not divisible by three round up and
round down and putting all the edges
between
different parts you can see this graph
here has no k4 okay so that's an example
of a k4 free graph there's a half the
maximum possible number of edges so is
this the best that we can do so it turns
out the answer is yes and that's the
next theorem that we'll see but just to
give it a name so we're going to call
graphs like these to run graphs okay so
next theorem is proved by Qur'an
Torrance term so turn on graph go to
node T and sub T sub n R it is a
complete our part I graph such that
there are n vertices whose parts sizes
are all nearly the same up to at most
one difference this is an example
general maybe you have our part and just
between different parts
so it's not too hard to calculate the
number of edges in such a graph and
Torrens theorem tells us that that is
the extreme example you cannot do better
in terms of getting more edges at most
[Music]
it's a generalization of meant helps
term and you can think about if the
proofs that we did for men tells them
and generalizes to Torrance term and
it's actually not entirely clear how to
do it so let me present for you three
three different proofs of Torrance
theorem so some of them you can think
about are they related to the proofs of
mint house term that we did and they all
are going to look somewhat different but
maybe superficially the first proof we
will use induction courtesies so this is
one of very few times in this course
where we will see induction so of course
induction is a powerful technique in
combinatorics but for almost the rest of
the course we're not gonna have clean
examples and when we do have clean
examples to work with somehow increasing
n by one doesn't buy you all that much
here you know there are very clean
examples very clean answers and
induction works out quite well
when n is small persue should always
address that can come up with many funny
proofs if you don't address small so any
small this promise
trivial and it's the most are you can
have the complete graph on our vertices
and then we're good so let's assume that
we're not in this case and also by
induction hypothesis let's assume that
it is true for all graphs fewer than n
vertices and let G be a graph that is K
sub R plus 1 3 on n vertices and also
let's assume a maximum example to begin
with so let's assume that the G that you
chose has already the maximum possible
number of edges they're only finally
such an example so pick one that already
has the maximum number of edges and
let's think about what properties this
graph G has I claim that G must already
contain a click on our vertices so think
about that if G does not contain your
click on our vertices then I can add in
more edges and I can still maintain the
property of being K sub R plus 1 so I
can assume that G must contain a K sub R
so let's look at one of these case of
ours so let M be the vertices so our
clique
gee we have some a and the compliments
that let me call that be alright look at
the vertex in B how many neighbors can
have in a it cannot be complete to a
otherwise I would have an R plus 1 click
so every vertex in B has at most R minus
1 neighbors a so let's count all the
edges the number of edges in G is that
most or first which to account for the
edges inside a and they are R choose two
of them and then the edges between a and
B for every vertex in B they are at most
R minus 1 vertices going to a to each
vertex and finally the edge set well we
can say something more about these
quantities we know that the size of B is
exactly n minus R but what can we say
about the number of edges in B we can
use induction hypothesis P is also R
plus 1 click free so the number of edges
is that most the number of edges in the
corresponding Terron graph now at this
point you can do a calculation well I
mean you should expect that the answer
we're looking for is I mean this should
be equal to the number of edges
in the toronto f so you can either do a
calculation to figure this out or
remember what i said earlier that keep
the type example in mind and everything
should check out for a height example so
in particular if you are in a situation
of a complete multi-part a graph with
equal size or nearly equal sized parts
what is a a is one vertex from each part
so you take out one vertex from each
part and read off this calculation for
this graph over here and then you see
that that is indeed equality so you
should check out you don't need to do
any actual calculations ok any questions
about the proofs we've done so far all
right
let me show you a another proof of
Tehran's theorem so this proof is as a
name so it's called Z cough
symmetrization the capacity
unfortunately only having a name that's
hard to beat in terms of alphabetical
watering if you and I were to write a
paper I wouldn't be the last often ok so
what's this about so let G be the graph
again as before we're going to take a
maximal example
so be the end vertex graph that is free
of clicks on R plus 1 vertices and has
already the maximum number of edges so
here's a property I want to prove about
this graph I claim that if you look at
the complement of the graph of this
extremal example
it must be an equivalence relation so
more precisely claim that if XY is a non
edge and Y Z is a non edge then X Z must
also be a long edge so in other words
non edges form equivalence relation
and again you should always think about
the extreme example it is true for the
extremo example because the compliment
are a bunch of clicks so it is an
equivalence relation
okay so let's prove this claim so let's
assume that the conclusion is not true
so suppose for the contrary that we have
XY and Y Z being non edges but XZ is an
edge so let's think about what happens
to the degrees of knowledge isn't
vertices so I claim that if the degree
of Y or smaller than the degree of X
then I can do something to the graph
that violates the maximality of the
number of edges namely I can replace Y
by a chrome of X so I chop off Y from
the graph and I look at X and I chrome
it so calling it means taking some X
Prime and a join X Prime to all the same
neighbors as X so Chrome X into some
other vertex X Prime now when you do
this I claim that you also get a graph
that is free of K sub R plus 1 so we
also obtain
a case up or plus one free graph case
why is that if you were to have an R
plus 1 Creek well it shouldn't have both
X and X chrome because there's no edge
between them so it only has one of X and
X cloned but then that would have been a
creek in the original graph however what
about the number of edges that we obtain
after this transformation if X had more
outgoing edges a higher degree than Y
then crowning X to replace Y increases
the number of edges we obtain a graph
that is also K sub R plus 1 and G which
is not possible because we assume that G
started with a maximum number of edges
so therefore the degree of Y is that
most the degree of X basically for every
edge XY likewise we also have that
there's no edge between y and z so the
degree of y is we have wise and Easter
the queer backs now so we have wives at
least now Y has a lot of outgoing edges
so now let's replace both x and z by
Chrome's of Y
as before we obtain some graph I will
call G Prime and G Prime
same reason as before is K sub R plus 1
3 right if you had a case of R plus 1
then the same clique should have shown
up in G so so G prime does not have R
plus 1 clicks either but what about the
number of edges in G prime so the number
of edges in G prime well we started with
G we deleted X and Z so we deleted this
many edges here were crucially using the
fact that there is an edge between X and
Z but now we also add it back in a bunch
of edges coming from the chrome of Y and
there are 2 times the Y edges added back
in and see because Y has degree at least
that of both X and Z we obtained that
this number of edges is strictly bigger
than that of G which contradicts the
maximality of G
so at this point we know that the
complement of G must be an equivalence
relation so the complement is a bunch of
clicks and that's that's a lot of
information right so that's almost the
best thing we can hope for is a
structural information we're not quite
done yet and why is that almost there
we're not quite done yet
okay so we need to figure out the sizes
of the individual parts so we need to
figure out the sizes of individual parts
and also note that you cannot have too
many parts so at this point after the
claim we know that G is a complete
multi-part a graph it has and most are
parts if it had R plus one parts I would
see a clique and R plus 1 vertices if so
and finally I need to show the rest is
fairly routine I need to show what the
part sizes have to be to maximize the
number of edges and basically if you had
some two parts so consider exactly our
parts are all empty parts is some two
parts half the number of vertices
differing by more than one then what I
can do is so if you had one part much
bigger than the other part and imagine
moving one vertex from one part to the
other part and should convince yourself
that this operation should strictly
increase the number of edges
moving vertices should strictly increase
the number of edges of G and putting
this all together we see that the
extremal example necessarily has to be a
current graph namely a complete our part
i graph where all the parts have the
same size up to almost one difference
okay any questions so the question is
can the zhukov symmetrization have been
confused for any other types of problem
I do have something else in mind but I
don't want to discuss it now
any more questions okay and you see that
in both proofs were if you look at this
proof as well you see that the tauren
graph is the unique extra measure I want
to give you a third proof that has a
somewhat different flavor so these two
proofs they're both somewhat
combinatorial in flavor so I'm doing
some arguments either looking at you
know in this case you click and arguing
what happens outside of it and over
there again looking at Maximo example
but the third proof I want to show is
more of a probabilistic proof so this
highlights an important method in
combinatorics known as the probabilistic
method where we start with a problem
that comes with no randomness but we
introduce some randomness to make the
problem amenable and it's a very pretty
idea
so we start again with G being and n
vertex K sub R plus one free well ommm
edges and what I want to do is to
randomly sort the vertex set consider a
random order so I put all the vertices
on the line where the vertices are
chosen in random order and you see some
of the edges
let me show you how to find a click and
essentially we do it in not so smart way
namely I basically pick all the vertices
in some greedy like manner where I
include a vertex in my set if it is
adjacent to all earlier vertices if if
all of its neighbors so I include V if V
is the earliest vertex
among its neighbors okay so earliest
means the leftmost go from left to right
so in this case up here look at the
first vertex well first of all taxes
should always be in your set this vertex
has one neighbors to the right that's
okay
and no sorry that's not what I want to
do so I actually do you mean when I was
initially V is adjacent to all the
earlier
vertices in this order but so for
example this vertex it's okay and I'm
also going to include this vertex here
yes it has both of its nativist earlier
vertices are in in both the earlier
vertices are adjacent to the third
vertex and I think that's it now this
set X I claim two things one that X has
to be a clique so clean the X has to be
a clique because every vertex in X is
two jacent to the earlier vertices in
particular all the vertices in X are
joined to each other on the other hand
how big is X at least in expectation so
for every vertex I want to understand
the probability that this V is included
in X all right so V has a bunch of non
neighbors and the property of being
included in X is that all of its non
neighbors up here after B so the
probability that V little B is in the
set X its equal to the probability that
B appears before all its no neighbors
all we and it's now neighbors they're
sorted uniformly so the probability that
this occurs is exactly one over one plus
the number of non neighbors which is n
minus the degree of P okay but we know
that this graph G has no cliques of size
R plus one so if we consider the
expected number of size of X on one hand
it has a most part because G 3 on the
other hand by linearity of expectations
for each vertex is included with some
probability so the size of X in
expectation is just the sum of all of
these individual inclusion probabilities
which individually we've computed above
like that now by convexity I can
conclude that this quantity this sum
here is at least the content without
would have been obtained if all the
degrees were equal to each other and if
you rearrange this equation this
inequality we obtain most one minus one
over R times N squared over two and if
you compare this number to the number of
edges in the current graph okay so you
see that this is basically the number of
edges and this gives you a proof and
it's divisible by R and in fact the
number of edges in the Terim graph is
exactly this number here if this
divisibility because condition is true
if it's not you need to do a little bit
more work because we were a little bit
lost here this step right so you should
see that this quantity here is minimized
when all the degrees are roughly equal
to each other and you make them as close
to switch to each other as possible okay
so with a little bit more work you can
get the exact version of Tehran's
theorem up there but at least what we've
shown yes from here we've shown that the
number of edges the number of edges is
and most this quantity which for most
purposes is basically as good as Torrens
theorem okay any questions about this
proof yet it's a probabilistic method
proof so we're introducing some
randomness into the problem that
originally had no randomness in it okay
great so let's take a very quick two
minute break and then when we come back
I want to show you that even though
we've shown so many different proofs of
Quran stir
and Telstra might think okay this is a
pretty simple thing even if I tweak the
problem just a little bit there are so
many things that we do not understand
and many important open problems in
combinatorics that are variants of
Turin's theorem so let's take a quick
break okay so so far we've been talking
about
Tehran's theorem or generally big
problem of if you forbid a certain
structure forbid a certain sub graph
what is the maximum number of edges
we're going to spend the next few
lectures discussing more problems of
that form and it turns out for the
questions that we've the answers we've
just seen they're deceptively simple and
for almost any other situation we don't
really know the exact answer and for
many questions we don't know anything
close to the truth I mean particularly I
want to show you one variant of this
problem namely what happens instead of
looking at graphs if you look at hyper
graphs and there that's a major open
problem in combinatorics what the truth
should be so here is an open problem
which is what happens to Tehran's
theorem for three scared by the word
hyper graph we actually think of graphs
as having edges consisting of pairs of
vertices a hyper graph is simply a
structure where three uniform hyper
graph the edges are triples triples of
vertices so question is what is the
maximum number of triples
in a graph without or for mental Sturm
we asked what happens without a triangle
for three uniform basic question you can
ask is what about forbidding a
tetrahedron so suppose you don't have
four vertices such that every triple
inside the four vertices is an edge
what's the maximum number of edges you
can have awaiting it's not so easy to
come up with good examples so two runs
to pick a bipartite graph complete
bipartite graph well here it's not so
easy to come up with examples but there
are some examples and in fact Iran
suggested the following construction
namely you divide the set of vertices as
before two three go for the equal sized
parts and let me take all triples that
look like one of the following forms
either three vertices one in each vertex
set or a triple looking like that two
vertex in one set one in the next set
we're going cyclically like that so I
include all triples one of these forms
and you should check that this
construction has no cave has no
tetrahedron if they had a tetrahedron it
would have had at least two vertices in
one part also then where the other two
vertices can be
so then how many edges does it have the
exact number is not so important but
what's important is that the edge
density of all the possible triples the
fraction of edges that are containing
this construction is 5 9 and it is
conjectured that this is open however
we're quite far from proving this number
so the best upper bound that that is
currently available and it's found quite
recently using this fairly new method in
graph theory called flag algebras
essentially a computerised way to try to
prove such inequalities and the best
upper bound is something like 0.56 2 and
it's a major open problem to either
prove or disprove that this construction
here is the optimal one so you see even
though I present there's so many proofs
of mental state materials during my at
this point hopefully they should all be
you know seem quite simple in retrospect
it's deceptive its deceptive and even if
I change and tweak the problem just a
little bit going to three uniform hyper
graphs instead of graphs we really have
no idea what's going on it's question
okay so great the question is why do I
say it's a pretty big gap so we know
that there has to be some proportion of
the total number of triples so well you
have two numbers and out there they
think I mean to me they seem pretty far
apart it's not it's not some lower water
gap so this is a first-order gap any
more questions but it's true that later
in the course we'll see gaps that are
much bigger know we'll see gaps where it
is like a polynomial on one side and a
power of Exponential's on the other side
and there I agree that's much worse so
the gap is much bigger here it's just
two numbers but you know in the worst
case that can be two numbers anything
any more questions
okay so throughout this course I'll try
to bring out some open problems and
there are they are lost so I'll tell you
what we do understand but most things we
do not understand and hopefully you know
some of you all go and try to understand
them better so the next time I teach the
course I can have something new to
present okay so then we've so now that
we've addressed the question of what's
the maximum number of edges if you
forbid a triangle or a clique the next
natural thing to ask is what about if
you forbid a general H so give me a
graph H and what's the maximum number of
edges if you're forbidden to do some
notation so the extreme what the note by
e^x and this is also called the Courant
number sometimes because Curran serum
hope you call it the extremal number or
frequently so this number here is
defined to be the maximum number of
edges in an vertex graph containing
I want to just clarify a piece of
notation
so when I say a sub graph so what do I
mean so there are several notions of
different kinds of sub graphs and the
couple that come up
somewhat frequently one is sub graph and
then there's something called induced
sub graph so probably easiest if I just
show you an example suppose my H is the
fourth cycle so an example of H being a
sub graph is suppose I have this graph
here so H is a sub graph of this graph
here in many different ways but in
particular like that but you see there
are some more edges that are among the
vertices but that's okay so sub graph
only requires you to have a subset of
vertices and a subset of edges whereas
induced subgraphs this is not an example
of induced sub graph so an induced sub
graph means that you take the set of
vertices and you look at all the edges
in the big graph
among your set of vertices so that's an
induced sub graph so here the fourth
cycle is an induced sub graph but not
induced sub graph over here so I just
want to make that distinction clear and
for now in this chapter we'll only talk
about sub graphs not induced necessarily
all right so let's recap what happened
for Terron still so Turin's theorem told
us that the extremal number of these
cliques well we know very precisely to
be the number of edges in the tauren
graph and in particular we saw from the
last proof and also similarly if you
just do a calculation that it is almost
this quantity over here and it's
basically that content so you can the
number of edges in the strong graph is
asymptotically that quantity up to and
the basic question is what about general
itch so if I give you some arbitrary
graph H what can you tell me about the
maximum number of edges in the graph
forbidding this H as a sub graph and it
turns out for most Atrus we have a
pretty good understanding and perhaps
quite surprisingly because you can
imagine this problem looks like it might
get quite complicated or all the proof
that we've done are very specific to
cliques but it turns out that we already
understand a lot and the critical
parameter that governs how this quantity
behaves is the chromatic number of H
so if you tell me the chromatic number
of H I can already tell you quite a lot
so just to remind you the chromatic
number of a graph is the minimum number
of colors you need to properly cover the
H I H is the minimum number of colors
needed to color the vertices of H so
that no two adjacent vertices have the
same color so for instance if I give you
a clique R plus 1 vertices so all the
vertices must receive different colors
because every pair of vertices adjacent
so the chromatic number is R plus 1 the
chromatic number of the tauren graph
it's our chromatic number of the Chiron
graphics are I can color each part in
this complete bipartite graph using a
different color and that's the best I
can do now if I have one graph being a
sub graph of another graph what can you
tell me about the relationships between
their chromatic numbers if H there's a
sub graph of G so what can you tell me
about relationship between their
chromatic numbers most high FG and why
is that
whatever coloring you do for G
use the same coloring and that's a
proper coloring for HS well so the
chromatic number of H might be smaller
but certainly cannot be bigger than that
of G so in particular if you have a
graph H with chromatic number or plus 1
then this Terron graph is always H 3 H
requires 4 colors it cannot be embedded
into the complete multi-part a graph on
three parts so the turn graph is also an
example of an H free graph with lots of
edges and this tells us that the
extremal number of H is at least that of
the store number fine
as one as the chromatic number minus one
okay so that's some lower bound
construction we saw earlier no we know
what the asymptotic is it's like for the
number of edges n goes to infinity and
now the question is is this the right
answer is it possible that we completely
missed some construction that might
produce a lot more edges and it turns
out and I think this should be somewhat
surprising because so far I feel like I
haven't really told you anything oh
that's surprising yet really mysterious
from but it turns out that this is more
or less the right answer so you cannot
do much better than the tauren graph
that for every graph H okay so if I fix
H then the limit as n goes to infinity
of the extremal number as a fraction of
total number of pairs so here this is
the edge density so this quantity here
is equal to 1 minus Chi of H so 1 minus
1 over Chi of H minus 1 so knowing the
chromatic number in some sense
completely determines how big the
extremal number should be and you see
that so far everything we've proved
Tehran's theorem and house term agree
with this formula here but if I give you
some H may be quite complicated and
those previous proofs don't work but
still you know the first water has some
tonics but there's still more to say but
first let me just run through some
examples for sanity check so if H is
triangle H chromatic number and this
limit so if H is the triangle chromatic
number 3 is 1/2 and that's indeed the
case that's what we did with mental
Sturm if H is a clique of four vertices
then the chromatic number is four and
the answer is two-thirds and also that
agrees with two runs to Greece with
Tehran's theorem but I can give you some
fairly complicated looking each so for
example H might be the Peterson graph
so every good graph theory course should
feature Peterson graph at least once
somewhere so that's the Peterson graph
what's the chromatic number of the
Peterson graph that's kind of a tricky
question the last time I taught this
course I even got the answer wrong so it
turns out you can three color the
Peterson graph okay so it's completely
not obvious how to do this perfume oh
there are only so many vertices if you
stir it long enough you can you can see
what happens but let me just show you a
three coloring at the Peterson graph
third color okay so that's a three
coloring of the Peterson graph that's
chromatic number three it's not - okay
so why is it now - it's not bipartite as
a five cycle which cannot be two colored
so then the limit is one half and here I
we can apply this theorem as a durstone
small image and I think it should be
somewhat surprising because the Peterson
graph looks quite complicated if you try
to forbid this graph in some big G it
seems like it's kind of hard to do but
it turns out the chromatic number
completely governs the behavior of the
extremal numbers but it turns out that's
not the entire story because well this
is quite a good deal and I said it gives
you the first water asymptotics actually
that's a lie it doesn't always give you
the first water asymptotics and when is
either strong shamone mesh not effective
or rather it's not the complete it's not
the final answer well you can say what
about this little okay so that so we're
still trying
understand you know there is a limit and
you can understand the one is the how
quickly there's a converge to this
number here okay so that's certainly a
valid question but more importantly
though if your graph is bipartite and
all this theorem tells you is that the
limit is equal to zero which somehow is
not the most satisfying answer you want
to know the first word there asymptotics
I mean this still tells you something
shamone master tells you that the
extremal number is N squared of course
you are a curious mathematician and you
want to know really what is the
asymptotics is it like n to the
three-halves
it's like n to the 4/3 you know what it
this is not satisfying and it turns out
from most bipartite graphs H it is a
very difficult problem that we still do
not know the answer to even what is the
order of the asymptotics
so the next few lectures what I want to
do is to show you some techniques that
will allow you to prove some upper
bounds for this extremal number in the
case when H is bipartite that shows you
that the exponent can be less than two
and I will also show you some
constructions that sometimes but in the
very few cases matches the upper bound
so there are very few examples of graphs
H from which we know the first order
asymptotics and for most graph H it is
their major open problems in common
network and there's some really old ones
which any solution might be quite
exciting
I will not show you a proof of
Adderstone small image now we will see
that later in the term once we've
developed some more machinery although
so later on in the term we'll see a
proof using the so-called similarities
regularity lemma which I've mentioned a
few times in the first lecture although
you don't actually need such heavy
machinery so there is so the original
proofs of errors in snow and stone first
proved this result for H being a
complete multi-part a graph and smaller
which observed that knowing H for a
complete multi-part I graph actually
implies this result in general so you
will not find a paper with all three of
them in being authors so later on in the
course once we've developed the
machinery of graph regularity Lamas I
will show you how you can deduce order
stone simonova CH from Tehran's theorem
somehow you use Tehran's theorem and
bootstrap it to address stone Shimano
venture so that should seem somewhat
magical right so on one hand you have
clicks and the other hand you have
things that somehow don't have clicks
they don't really look like clicks but
you can still bootstrap one to the other
and so after we develop some machinery
won't do that but the earths are
combinatorial proof which doesn't use
any of this heavy machinery so you can I
won't discuss it in this lecture but you
can look it up and it's it's quite nice
it has some combinatorial techniques and
some double counting arguments I want to
okay so going forward I want to show you
some questions
mostly questions but some answers as
well so questions such as what is the
extremal number of so what are some of
the basic bipartite graphs one of them
is just a complete bipartite graph so
this for the 0 and k which problem and
for some values of s and T we know the
answer but for most values we have no
idea what the answer is for
4k4 for we do not know what is the
correct exponent so even fairly small
cases so this is all to show you that
you know these simple proofs that we did
today they are perhaps too deceptively
simple even if you change the question a
little bit we don't understand a lot so
so questions like this will occupy the
next several lectures and I also show
you some constructions and there are
some constructions that used nice
algebraic ideas and some probabilistic
idea so have see ideas coming from many
different sources I want to close off by
just a cultural remark so in this course
especially the the first half will
encounter a lot of Hungarian names we
already thought a couple of them and I
just want to give you a very quick
tutorial on how to pronounce Hungarian
names because for cultural purposes now
in the past when I taught this class
there were no Hungarian speakers but I
think we do have at least one Hungarian
speaker in the room so I want you but
but you are native Hungarian speaker so
you should tell us okay so can you
pronounce help us pronounce these names
this shamone [ __ ] yep
so the one I'll just tell you two things
about Hungarian names one of them is
that the S it's pronounced like Shh and
another thing that comes up is s Z which
we saw in samurai D so this was
pronounced like s forget the Z others
another thing about a dish that you
should know is that what is this accent
it is not a double dot tag you would
type it as / H just a few cultural
remarks about about names okay great so
we'll end today and then next time we'll
start looking at other extremal numbers
for more bipartite graphs